all right i want to release the wheel
again or do this more i think probably
spin wheel i mean this is fun but
up to you guys let's get more variety
let's spin the wheel hang on i gotta buy
stuff in the catalog
[Music]
whoa the atto meek
there was an atomic submarine is that a
new ship oh yeah
i am buying that let me read you the
description of the atom
this enormous nuclear powered vessel in
all its technological wonders
invincibility purge a unique ability to
channel this vessel's nuclear energy
into a temporary aura of invincibility
meltdowns engineers must manage power
carefully as heat will build up over
time and cause fiery chaotic outbursts
throughout the vessel if not purged
irradiated glow no need for lights it
constantly glows two weapons shielding
spacious atom age interiors and design
with three to four player crews in mind
oh the nuclear age is here i'm buying it
the ship of the future the ship of the
future i should have out of it what are
we doing this zipper diffuser oh my god
you guys
diarrhea is an outfit
i am a diarrhea
all right shall i spin the captain wheel
in the wheel of captaining all right
i gotta type it back in again
hold on i think we all just like leave
it open in a time i should have done
that yes i left the the roll wheel open
i did not leave the captaining wheel
with the atomic we have to purge
pressure you can't speak to the captain
that way
[Applause]
you have to speak
my captain
i've been a
fool
who does what sir i will determine who
does what to where and why
and i get to do power and advocacy
[Laughter]
it really knows me it knows me
hey that's how we get deeper yeah you
guys do whatever you want to do
i'm a fun captain look you don't have to
hide from me
yeah
of course you can drive of course thanks
yeah call me cap cappy whatever you want
this is a pleasure cruise i'll get the
wrench don't worry uh i'll do wrench i'm
not gonna do pipe wrench because pipe
wrench doesn't repair nearly as fast
punctured so that can flood off you wow
okay so what is the deal with this
nuclear submarine
whoa oh
my goodness dude
[Laughter]
look at that
wow
what level or is the accommodation on
all the guns are the bottom level oh
everything's at the bottom
what's in the middle oh my god bizarre
science
i'm going to try something what is this
aura of invention why is there a room
empty that's the purge that we have to
do so often which i don't know how to do
it
now look at our atomic sparkles wait
where's the purge activated so someone
said
that the thing accumulates heat and that
the engineer needs to purge heat or we
will explode into fiery nuclear melt now
okay so that's the that's the
invincibility or i believe and what's
going on
i'll take the weird helmeted thing
okay i'll take the nuclear
nuclear motion sickness so i don't know
how i know what's hot
i'm sure it'll inform you with some sort
of glowing and or
yeah
hotness probably when you feel your
bones disintegrating all right
hey guys remember fun times here
pleasure cruise enjoy the atomic drill
those attached to each of your beds
only the best for my group
yeah
i need to remember i'm front gun
[Music]
oh my god i can't purge
holy shark on the bottom right
don't yell at each other like say it in
a cool format yeah i know you're right
i'm sorry
captain permission to force everybody to
say things nicely the captain approved
hey you guys there's a grumbly there's a
shark to the right of us friends going
up kind of
okay still have no idea where an
indication of temperature is there's a
spar fish oh the starfish mist it's okay
we're fine we if you hold q we when we
shake violently
oh good purge good perks
that's what i need to do i see i work on
that
permission to ask wait to heal me ah
permission granted
uh wait can you heal me thanks captain
all right guys i think we could fit
through this little butt crack butt
crack over here
yes left butt crack is good interesting
story our ship doesn't really show up on
the radar
oh we're getting stuck down everybody
right into that one wow they wouldn't
need topped off
i'm good
gab needs a few smooches if you know
what i mean
oh captain you
you got it thank you nothing weird
happened at all hey you guys take your
leave because you feel like it thanks
[Applause]
way better than the last captain this
captain was a stick in the mud yeah but
it's different here you guys have fun
just come back safe all right i'll i'll
let you know when dinner's ready wait
he's not
he's not coming with us
i'm even the one wearing the chef's
outfit this is really nice
i'm still alone
i came to battle with us
i can't hear a thing oh how [ __ ] gonna
take a nap in the drill doo bed
questioning is leadership a little bit
at this point if i'm totally honest
it's not great but at least he's nice
about it it's kind of like things just
happen around him
like we're killing narugo the
uncrackable
we did that yeah i mean we did that
we don't need him we did that without
him
one of us has to mention he has a wrench
we're still doing it
i have a gun
we didn't have to nice the captain that
we got that money no dude hydrogen
for ourselves hide that necklace hey
captain
hey
all right so you find anything out there
you find anything good
that's a shame all right well if you did
find anything it would be property of
the captain just so you know i'm not
saying you did but oh yeah no no we know
we're not absolutely fair yeah no yeah
all right cool you wouldn't even think
about betraying you
why would you yeah i would never have
done that don't even know what the word
betray means i don't know why you would
strain
hey there's a shark to the right there
fellas
took that teamwork
good teamwork guys all thanks to me and
my incredible captaining skills hey bob
i'm just giving you some smooches while
you pile it oh thanks i like to wrap my
arms around you while you're working
oh that's nice you get a good mustache
i'll inhibit him
did you find any necklaces out there
no i don't think because as my arms are
wrapped around you i do notice through
all the mud that i do detect a little
bit of uh
nemo is eating us sir
please stop nemo
wow
over here
here we go
coming back up here we go all right
we're kicking holes
we're good things are good fixing holes
yep we're fixing those 19 health if you
could just patch just fix a couple more
holes
yep
all right almost got all the holes i'm
actually gonna keep us over here uh team
friends does anyone need to lose the
holes got him all right you could do it
a little single smooch not the drill
though bed where oh we still need guns
there's still a shark out there maybe
one person doing gun things all right
coming back
going back to the goal that was great
guys that was real that was really
really good yeah i'll be more mindful of
purging this heat here
stop uh
accusing people of things and started
doing your job okay good i was like we
might need another purge we're starting
to shake a little bit yeah all right
captain's on it kevin's on it
captain
oh
what happened to him not sure grabbed
murdered
there's nothing the i'm getting the
layer guardian away from the ship
okay fix hole oh hole
is my med kit on the ship oh man if only
i wasn't grabbed from the guns and
dragged out
yeah
i'm at three health
probably on the ship's bill guys this uh
pleasure cruise i'm not hearing much
pleasure
captain i am
you're welcome hey who needs love
touches
i'm i'm sleeping it off notice you have
some gold on your corpse there
just know this must have been from his
his greedy hand that grabbed me must be
covered in gold captain i just noticed
these things you know i noticed many
things many things are noticeable to my
eyes kill him dad we're trying he's
nothing but nuts
oh he's misty watch out for that whoa
he's trying to grow wow
that hurt yeah this is not a [ __ ]
sign to be on
[Music]
pretty chilly just launches a drone
every once in a while it's really not so
bad any stomps
kind of cute he's almost dead
later guardian more like
idiot
now this is getting more pleasurable
guys
this is real nice
look at that what did we get captain
what is that i can't tell
i can pick it up oh
freeze freezing
you take your old gun and drop it on the
ship and now that
is that
does that hurt captain
feels good
he's so much more captain than he ever
get up here captain
well
the feeling of power that i once felt
oh wait somebody
somebody can grab the backpack and have
a med kit we can have two med kits
i got a backpack
you want the med kit too
sure captain i don't know how you want
to kept it in your small house
uh i don't either
nobody's
out how to switch items that are in your
backpack oh oh right click right click
so uh what else you got there
you doing uh
atomic age gun and whoa oh big man
all the more to heal you with now uh if
you could just aim that a little lower
oh he's tiny
whoa
captain you're so girthy
earthy captain
captain the way your package throbs
i i don't know if we if that gun is good
or bad i don't yeah what if you shoot an
enemy with it and it makes them bigger
yeah what if it makes it smaller you
know
how do you make it smaller versus bigger
so fine smaller is like aim at the feet
and bigger is like aim at the head weird
what about the dick
no and i'm taking
[Music]
oh
all right back to the ship guys
it was a fun time but we got to get
moving does anyone need help no no no
engine up guns up
shields up oh i thought they're going to
die my max health is lowered to 9.
look at that we need to purchase
no no we don't need to purge we don't
need we're glowing we're
this is what purge looks like
okay good oh purge
uh we got smacked but no damage yet
oh because we've got shields
invincibility mode if we get in trouble
no no i don't even
reverse captain oh we've got a
civilization to visit and ruin let's go
[Applause]
all right guys i want you guys to have
some pleasure out there just whoa
all right maybe yeah one two three four
depth that's epic
dude that's nutty whoa we need to go
deeper
permission to make fun of their fish
faces sir
yes please make fun of look at your face
remember
it's all in good fun
it's a backpack
there's a guidance
i would like a backpack but i'm curious
about the guidance laser yeah i don't
know what that is we could all chip in
for that i think somebody should get the
backpack so we can have either another
weapon or another if one person gets a
backpack no three of us
the captains say we pull for the laser
the backpack laser ring
the backpack may be fun and allow us to
have some more versatility but there's
always good to be had with a laser
i have to say what captain do you have
them do what kevin say okay
we need one more
oh person yeah does anyone else have any
funds left
no i meant
the whole baby yep i'm so close to the
backpack i still have 68 what do we do
with it
oh come on munitions sites you have
lasers on your guns oh yeah okay
i love that i love that wait did we go
up it's just a throwing up there oh a
throne oh make fun of them
tiny fish people haha
yeah
you just got landed wow all right
everyone on board
unborn
all right here we go sir permission to
have fun
oh my god look at those lasers
how inaccurate i am even more now that
is
hey aim your laser at the fish
the guy fish fish their lasers were
different colors
that would be a little bit come on what
he is
on the back you're basically at opposite
ends yeah you know guys
you're right
you're right
i know i'm wrong
all right
can we do damage if we kill them all
right shooter mcgavins
isn't it better to kill them now before
they pop and get us and swarm us
maybe
maybe
yeah whatever just kill the big one get
freezed on and i'm going to purge
oh sick purge good purge captain good
virgin
no that was good
whoa that was less good
that was much less
where's that
it's in the bedroom there's also a crack
in there
okay
oh don't worry the captain's got that
captain's got this
oh we're nailing them oh possible
intruder
it's vomiting vomiting them out now
it's doing a vomit us i'll get him i'll
get him you focus on the big boy
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
getting
[Laughter]
shoot up to push him down
but we can just shoot if you think oh
feast and marcus wants to get sick
oh yeah this feels right don't worry
i've got snacks on my hat guys my repair
was boosted good good
my phone was boosted it's as good as it
has ever been fun
all right we're going for it perch we're
shaking oh well it's probably whoa
definitely purge
purge good thinking
but that's invince that's solid
invincibility feel free to run into
anything
this nuclear sub sync so fast do we have
extra engines or something this i got
you a little bit more spice all right
we're worth zooming right now tell you
what why is this spicy we are absolutely
descending if you know what i mean oh i
do i do hey bob how would you like a
little more pizzazz
i do oh yeah no yeah do it give it to me
yeah that's the stuff
yeah now we're going deep
navigating
i've ever wanted
this is everything we could out for i've
never seen navigation like this
we're gonna drag a little ass
okay it's all
right don't worry i'll just drive right
around
oh my god
i'm working on it you just gotta give
oh we're running we're fleeing for our
lives
he's
okay there's one more leak somewhere
oh
there might be something
got it got it got it got it
i can't believe we got out of that so
healthy hey what a crew
what a regular here sean
whoa what about one of these
and what about what
what a gunners what a crew what an
engineer captain mix hybrid yeah
a cave yes the cave oh my gosh
well done guys well done gang that was
the tiny
drift of submarine exploration
dude
hot if you want more speed we could just
all hold on for dear life and uh nothing
but speed max speed max speed don't need
to shoot or anything if you're not there
to get hit all speed shields
conrad
whatever that was it was too sturdy i
don't like it feel his body
killed body [ __ ] his wife okay these are
bound to only have treasure in them
don't worry about it oh yeah in that
order oh yeah in that order
guys i picked up some fuel uh wait do
you do any damage to the enemies
i have no idea all right he doesn't it's
just good to keep swinging all right
he's just healing oh hey there's a
there's a man he jumped down there
sorry captain had them captaining things
to do
i understand it's a former captain
myself
hey i found a snail and a clam uh where
are you from oh behind us guys
okay we're killing three snails right
now
okay oh that's pretty neat
we could kill these guys too
nice wow nice good job well we'll
backpack here
hey when are you guys gonna have this
backpack feel free aren't i the only
other one who doesn't have a backpack
yet either oh well you take it with you
you're doing more stuff than i am kind
of just driving the boat yeah that way
if we get a wrench i can get a wrench to
help fight and heal stuff that would be
nice
oh skeleton helps help lap that's what
that would do
uh i don't see him
always
beating the [ __ ] out of me
you were waving your thing in the air
i literally there's not wait just leave
okay
wait i think you're hallucinating i
think you need to get in the boat yeah
you might need to get in the boat i
think there was mushrooms in that
backyard i think our gunner has ocean
madness yeah i i have an idea
captain's got an idea called this uh
call this the the my skirm drift
you better let go of those guns and hold
on to something tight
all right here we go boys that's what
i'm talking about
yes that's what i said and we're headed
yep it's okay
it's fine it's fine just prepare it's
all good
the command man is dying
oh
i'm going in the cave
oh my god
[Applause]
i'll get the guardian i'll get the
guardian all right
who's the guy who's the guy
save each other how do we get him i
don't know how to get you down
shoot his hand yeah i'm shooting his arm
oh yay there you go buddy no no you
don't go buddy i don't want to be here
i'm shooting his arm sir
oh
nice nice good
this is teamwork this is teamwork
this is dreamworks
he's
the arm is moving is that good no no
arm's gone
i need a heel i need a heel please
i get i need to go
i need the heel
we all gather up over here we can heal
together all right that sounds good i
don't want to be that close i'm a gun
boy he doesn't even have any moves your
moves are weak this is
like spits out drones we did like easy
chop off his grabby arm so that seems
kind of unfair i didn't even know that
was like a thing you could do can you
shoot him in the head oh never mind
all right boys maybe
what is that super engine
emp recharge
no
wait no that's bad we just overheat more
doesn't it well just purge a lot all
right
[ __ ] it
we drift
that's what we be
hey wait gun gun wait what was the thing
that we had to turn water into steam
well no one has it but there is an item
in the game that is a water pump
oh i thought it was a thing on the ship
all right
wait i can shoot
i dare you to use the fuel on this one
all right as fast as physically if we
get into any trouble whatsoever we're
out of this [ __ ] all right good
that's the way it is give me navigation
though give me at least general left
permission to get in the whale yes in
the whale
[ __ ] a
whale whoa
field charge cell and repair elixir
um maybe shield charge cell oh maybe
that sounds like a permanent that sounds
beautiful
like all whole breeches get fixed
all right well we have a good amount of
money how much can you buy that yourself
wade uh no that's a i got close i'm
adding now let's see and bam okay yeah
at 650
i like that oh we can get the repair
elixir if you think that sounds fun i
don't even know what it does i have no
idea
sure the battery gives you an um that's
how we add extra guns it gives you an
extra charge
on the thing temporary unfortunately we
need one more layer
yeah we need one more goose
oh i thought i i'm i'm out i thought we
had enough anyone got coins you just got
it ooh oh okay nice yeah all right let's
go
we are the better probably
drift
yeah no this will be fine this is gonna
be fine
right left
i think it was just generally it's a
rare pair speed upgrade like altogether
whoa okay left and down
trippy
we're going baby
we're going and then if this is the boss
which it looks like it might be i'm
going to switch to
actually i'm going to go ahead and drop
it and bring it yep there you go okay
okay who knows where it is it's
sightless
[Music]
you're hitting it
[Music]
bye